what's up everyone welcome back to the
cinema center at marble at Tiff 2023 I
have the team behind boy kills world
with me I already said this to you off
camera but wow what an ambitious
audacious film you have made
congratulations
I don't know who wants to do these
honors but a lot of our viewers will
first be learning about your film
through the Festival so who would like
to give a synopsis of boy kills world
it's a wild and crazy mashup of every
uh every film genre and movie that
Moritz grew up loving and it comes from
every corner of his mind and he somehow
integrated elements from all of those
great movies he has that classic
filmmaker story of having worked in a
video store
when he was younger and uh and just
being an avid cinephile and I think you
see the influences of anime
of the Great Master action movies the
the best comic book movies you've seen
um his his Inspire he can talk about his
own inspiration but this movie is
basically a Revenge movie but it's fun
it's about family it's also about family
and sort of how families can be a little
messed up
um it's kind of like Revenge it is an
exploration of the Python that you go on
on Revenge but it's also about being
manipulated by other people there's kind
of a deep message in there buried uh
beneath the Mayhem the wild and crazy
action and the comedy and uh it's just
it's a little bit of everything it's
fresh that's a that's a very accurate
description given the fact that this
movie is a little bit of everything it
was making me wonder when you were
working on the script did you have a
break story moment a particular thing
you came up with that made you say to
yourself now that we have this it's
coming together and we're good to go
the script we worked on the script for a
couple of years I think uh
uh the first draft was done after a year
and then we sort of finessed it over a
another seven eight months
um
there are a lot of moments where I was
like oh this is cool now we're doing
something different and now this is fun
like stuff that we were sort of
struggling with at first and suddenly it
just clicked I can tell you sort of a
specific thing
um
but there are a lot of these moments
um yeah to build on that a little bit
what would you say is the biggest
difference between draft one of your
screenplay and what everyone's gonna see
in the finished film now
I don't know if you even should spoil
that but the biggest difference is
um
we have a boy is talking to his uh go
sister
and at in the first draft it wasn't his
sister it was a younger version of
himself so there was a sort of a Bruce
Willis the kid moment there we had him
as a young boy and him as an adult and
uh but uh we sort of talked about it oh
he has to sort of his sister is dead and
um
so he has to like how does he process
this and so he we had all these
conversations about the old guy talking
to the younger his younger version about
his sister and at one point we were like
why are we doing this why couldn't he
just talk to his sister
and that's what changed and that's was a
big change and there was a big click in
aha moment for us and uh I'm very happy
that that happened interesting both
paths are interesting but I'm glad you
landed on what you did here and we
brought on this amazing writer Tyler
Burton Smith he did
um he did a lot of rewriting on the film
and he really punched it up and made it
super original and and wonky and kooky
as as you know very much so see now but
I wanted to come to you next
specifically to talk about raymie
Productions a little bit because I I
love Sam Raimi I've been following his
films literally my entire life for you
as a filmmaker as a producer yeah what
was something about like the company's
initiative that Drew you to it and maybe
thought maybe made you think you could
grow there as a filmmaker as well yeah I
mean Sam is so supportive of young
filmmakers and it's really important to
us to really
really work on Original Stories and um
and when we you know when we were
developing maritza's script as you it's
everything's original it's bold it's
creative and Sam loved everything about
maritza's brain is there anything I feel
like there's going to be a million
answers to this question is there
anything in this script that when you
were gearing up for production made you
think like there's gonna be a first I
don't know if we're gonna be able to do
it but we're gonna try it for the very
first time
um there is a lot there's a lot of yeah
I don't know what I can give away but
there's a lot of Firsts
um
the cheese grater was a fun one and Evil
Dead rise did have it but we shot it at
the same time I will say
um all the action was incredible and
there's just so much heart and the World
building there's I mean I can go on and
on about how incredible the film is I
don't think there is anything wrong with
calling 2023 the year of the
cheeseburger
we know that the cheese grater is in the
movie can you talk a little bit about
the the special effects involved on set
in order to pull off action like that
special effects on set
um well what we did what we had to do to
even get a sort of a
a basic picture of how the action should
look was doing all these previous things
where we uh shoots where Dave shatarski
the action director sort of worked out
the general gist of the scene then we
talked about it then we made the changes
according to the script and then he sort
of shot the first draft of it in a
warehouse in the stunt facilities
basically and uh then re-did it sort of
on set on the day and obviously even
then there was a there were changes but
that was sort of one big thing so we
could really anticipate how much time
it's going to take us because it's just
so much like so much action and uh yeah
really we went in and really tried to
have a plan way before that and that uh
that affected the visual effects like
every time somebody goes in like yeah he
could shoot him in the head right now
he's like oh yeah that's another bullet
impact blood spatter another muzzle
flash oh yeah that's another five one
thousand five hundred dollars or
something so every time somebody like a
small idea it literally affected the
budget and um
uh yeah but we did it yeah the the crazy
challenge you have them right like
maritza's are covering is like we've
you've got the action sequences the
drama sequences the humor beats and
they're all having to work together and
David and Moritz uh created these crazy
action sequences where David wanted to
create fight sequences that included
things that he's always wanted to do as
a stunt designer and coordinator and
never been allowed to do and we sort of
turned him loose and yet you go ahead
Dave just let's go crazy let's do this
um and then integrating them into the
drama and the moments um and you know
one of the biggest challenges you've got
a lead actor who has no dialogue he's
deaf and mute uh that that leads to a
very different challenge in shooting the
movie that Moritz really did an amazing
job with to capture the emotion and the
heart and with the lead with no lines oh
I have many questions about that I do
want to know what visually is important
for you in order to capture that emotion
but then also when did you come to the
conclusion that having that voice over
narration was also an effective way to
bring all those emotions to screen I
mean that was basically from the
beginning like the very first moment we
started when we shot the proof of
concept trailer in uh 2016 16 I think
um that was one of the core ideas that
we had to make this movie different to
add something that is not usually in an
action movie and uh yeah that's where it
started like that was one of the first
ideas we had that was the importance of
Bill Bill was drawn to the action but he
loved the idea that he's going to have
this additional challenge of of you know
having to like show the EXP express
everything while he's in the middle of a
fight or in the middle of a scene and
yes the voiceover all helped that but
really his on-screen performance the way
he and Moritz work together to make sure
we captured that like your lead actor
has to be looking in the direction of a
sound or somebody who's talking to him
if he's going to react to it yeah uh
things like that little things yeah can
you tell us a little bit about working
with Bill as an actor's director now
maybe even something unique about the
way he works that demands something
different from you as an actor's
director compared to everyone else in
the Ensemble so yeah one big thing was
the fact that he didn't have any
dialogue but he had dialogue right he
was when he was when he talks to his
sister uh there is a dialogue there so
you had to
shoot it in a way that you knew the
timing you knew the performance
the back and forth between the two of
them is like have her line then him sort
of mimicking the line keeping the timing
his head then she answers so that was a
big Challenge and we came up with all
these crazy Solutions sort of uh putting
a re pre-recorded putting it in his ear
putting it in her ear so he could have
that and after we tried all of this we
came to the conclusion that simpler is
better and basically just shot it once
with him doing the dialogue so we had a
sort of a baseline for timing and and
for his emotion and how he would act it
out and then just sort of winging it on
the shoot for the timing just like that
yeah that this would work because also
you don't have time to do these
complicated things over and over for for
a line the a dialogue can't be the
something that takes the longest in a
movie like
I love talking about winging I want to
come back to the rest of the cast
eventually but I do love talking about
winging it because with a film like this
you already brought up previous you want
to plan plan to set yourself up for
success but sometimes the unexpected
magic is the stuff that is the most
special thing in a film so can you give
me an example of a day on set when
things weren't going to plan you found a
creative way to Pivot and it improved a
scene because of it it's a lot yeah it
happens it happens a lot we're like oh
that's a lucky coincidence uh I don't
actually know if it's in the if it's in
the script but we sort of had the young
version of boy Cameron or Nicholas I
don't know who it was doing uh chopping
wood and uh
the ax the head of the prop X came off
Angela just flew away and he sort of
hits it and we kept it in the movie and
I'm not sure if it's still in there but
for the longest time we kept it in there
was like this is really funny because
they had this like came off and then he
had this expression like oh and that was
really funny but stuff like that happens
all the time uh either at the end of the
scene or the beginning of the scene
where you're like oh I didn't know that
was coming but uh it it's hard to
pinpoint another Zion Zion's lines
yeah yeah
Isaiah Mustafa right uh he sort of just
ad-libbed a lot of the The Lion The his
nonsense lines that he sort of uh
delivered and it cracked me up every
time I'm just like hearing so many of
them right now yeah there's one of those
things like how how do you kind of
convince yourself when you're just
looking at the page that like something
like that will wind up working I feel
like until the words are in his mouth
you just don't get it did it in casting
uh and uh that and even casting we were
like oh my God this is gonna work
because having somebody like him sort of
with a straight face delivering these
nonsense lines like we're laughing so
hard
I feel like some of the you need to make
t-shirts and just put those lines
and to his credit he came a up with a
lot of them like we wrote like I think
we even I guess we doubled the lines in
the movie like we like he only had half
the lines in the in the script and yeah
he just kept delivering great stuff so
we were like oh yeah sure that's gonna
be in there he randomly changed them
between texts
yeah it was very hard to not to stay
quiet we were laughing so hard on
Saturday yeah in ADR
he just added again and they're like oh
my God there's even more now I'm fine
the more that you have in this movie The
Better exactly I feel like he might be
one of the answers to this question but
of all the supporting roles around bill
which character did you find the
toughest to cast where it required a
real search to find the perfect fit but
also who was someone who just like
magically appeared one day and you're
like we immediately have the right actor
for this character I think the last one
was uh was Andrew Koji because uh we
were sort of looking for for older
actors for that role so to say more
seasons just like I think 10 15 years
older because we're like oh yeah yeah
that's that's gonna fit there and uh I
think sign up brought him up and uh
we're developing another film with Koji
uh a biopic and uh and he was just
talking about how he always wanted to
try comedy you know he's the lead in a
show called Warrior and
and he felt that he was always Typecast
so when we it was the role was
originally ciao
and maritzan Koji met and Magic yeah
yeah it was and I I didn't know that but
I thought it was always funny because he
worked on Warrior and Warrior also shot
in Cape Town so a lot of the team
already knew him from his from the show
and uh they were like
yeah who that guy is usually different
and it was only then that I realized he
was basically in character the moment we
first got on the call like on the first
call and he already had this yeah he
already in character and uh that just
blew me away and it's um it was a big
surprise yeah so he he came to the
project the quickest easiest to cast
what's the opposite Now who is the most
difficult character to find the perfect
actor for
I think the hardest was finding the
young sister yeah yeah that's true that
was a global search
Worldwide thank you
thank you
she did a great job we looked at a lot
of a lot of young girls yeah and uh
it was hard it was really hard but she's
an amazing young actress just definitely
she just wanted a an award I think it
was not an maybe an Emmy but yeah
for children yeah I must look that up
yeah but great success that search paid
off big time I have to wind down with
you all soon but Cena because you just
brought up another film with Andrew Koji
now I'm thinking I want to know other
things that you have coming up in the
future because you're or at least IMDb
tells me you're working with many other
genre directors that I deeply admire and
love is there any update on the project
that you're working on with Rob Savage I
actually have three movies with Rob only
one has been announced there's no better
answer to that question than what you
just said
um
three movies with Rob and it's funny I I
discovered him before he made any of his
movies he made those little shorts and
he was so brilliant and then blumhouse
beat us like made those films really
quickly
um he's incredible we have another movie
with Andrew Koji in development and the
next film actually we're shooting in
Vancouver uh is also with Bill Skarsgard
so I will be teaming up with Bill again
you keep working with good people I'm
sorry if I'm pressing for too much
information but the films with Rob is
any of are any of those going back to
the screen life format or are they going
to be more traditionally shot films
along the lines of let's say Boogeyman
do you mean streaming uh screen life
like host versus Boogeyman
host and host and dash cam more like
Boogeyman yeah I got a lot of faith in
him yeah I'll bug you about one more too
okay Corin Hardy corn Hardy yeah is that
is that still gonna happen yes it is
um we are working on it and he's
currently shooting a film in Toronto
right now and uh we are hoping that this
film every house is haunted will be the
next one for next year I'll leave you
all with one question that I like to to
end on quite a bit because I am a big
believer that no one in this industry
tells themselves good job nearly enough
we say it to other people but not our
ourselves can you tell me one specific
thing you accomplished on boykills world
that you know you can walk away from the
production look back on it and say to
yourself damn I am proud we pulled that
off that's a heavy question
I'm gonna let zainab go first
I'll go
I'll go for over 6
or 6 um I love how diverse our film is
and colorful and when you watch the film
everybody looks different everybody
brings a little spice to the film it's
it's so special it's nothing I've ever
seen before or worked on before and I'm
really excited for everyone to watch it
tonight spot on answer I I would say the
same I think we are just the whole
project from the beginning until the end
was audacious aggressive it was really
difficult it wasn't easy there are so
many devices that come out of this man's
mind that are integrated into the story
and I think the finished product is
remarkable but but I can say honestly
with our production team whether it was
with Emma Stone Remy vertigo and in Tiba
pictures it was a really challenging
movie all around and really my favorite
thing is was standing in the auditorium
this morning looking at the movie at the
Royal Alexandra and going this is
happening we're a tiff and we're going
to show into an audience tonight and I'm
so proud of everybody's work
for me it's really sort of having this
the the team surrounding the movie The
Action director the production designer
the DP like all all of them
and all of them love the movie like they
really went out of the way to to
do their best like we had a lot of
yelling and people yelling at other
people going like this is the best thing
I've done for 10 years and you're not
ruining this for me it's going to go my
way and like like stuff like that
they're really like passionate about it
and you're like oh my god the guy feels
exactly the same as me and that that was
a great feeling to to talk to these
people and see that they feel so much
for this movie so I'm gonna really happy
with that oh I love that answer so much
I'm gonna say again congratulations on
boy kills world thank you and I will
remind our viewers keep an eye out for
the movie as well and also for more
interviews from the cinema center coming
your way very very soon